la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
tous ensemble pour sauver la culture du
manioc à l'initiative du cirad et de
l'ird et l'institut de recherche pour le
développement des chercheurs et experts
de 13 pays africains se sont retrouvés
récemment lors d'un séminaire au pôle de
protection des plantes à saint-pierre
objectif jeter les bases d'un réseau de
surveillance mondiale des maladies
virales et bactériennes qui touche le
manioc
je dirais d'abord que c'est une très
bonne initiative parce qu'en tant que
chercheur à l'université mais ray à
blois
je coordonne un projet cinéma l'a dit
les ravageurs du manioc
donc il était intéressant de venir on
part à cette activité qui avait impliqué
des chercheurs d'autres papes du monde
parce que souvent tant que chercheur nos
travailleurs de manière isolée
donc c'est bien mais vraiment mettre
tout le monde ensemble ont conspiré
converger nos vues en vue de pouvoir
mener une lutte efficace contre les
maladies dont on part sur une maladie
causée par l'éveil ce quatrième source
de calories dans les pays tropicaux 700
millions de personnes à travers le monde
dépendent en effet du manioc pour leur
sécurité alimentaire d'où l'importance
et la nécessité de préserver et de
développer cette ressource
une des raisons importantes aussi c'est
que le manioc va très bien résister au
réchauffement climatique
le manioc peut pousser à des très hautes
températures il répond très bien aux co2
et par conséquent et il est déjà
résistant à la sécheresse
donc le magnen qu'on sait déjà
aujourd'hui que le manioc va permettre
de fournir beaucoup plus de nourriture
que les céréales par exemple en afrique
par contre on sait aussi que les
maladies du manioc du fait de
l'augmentation de la températures vont
exploser
et donc il est certain que si on veut
prendre avantage de cette plante il faut
en même temps développer des recherches
et des outils les instruments pour
pouvoir limiter le développement de ces
mairies et c'est là où notre il peut
aussi jouer un rôle important
grâce aux infrastructures du pôle de
protection des plantes et de ses équipes
de chercheurs compétentes la réunion
pourra apporter sa contribution dans ce
programme international de lutte
entre les maladies du manioc isolement
de cette île est un grand avantage
on parlait avant de connaître tous
l'existence des 3 b et c ont parlé
d'aller monter sa hawaï dans le milieu
du pacifique
on l'a déjà ici et c'est plus proche de
l'afrique
ici on voit que on a des facilités 13
très bon pour faire de la recherche sur
les manières ce qui sur les maladies
virales et c'est bien sûr que la réunion
peut contribuer à ces biens pour la for
global contre les maladies virales
manioc
car au final ce sont bien les petits
producteurs qui devrait profiter à terme
des retombées de ces recherches
selon l'afrique c'est surtout la
pratique les petites voilà producteurs
qui produisent de manière plus donc si
l'on remonte leurs revenus ils vont
avoir plus de moyens pour augmenter
encore voilà productivité donc quand on
pense un peu à eux dans notre rôle de
chercheur trouver des solutions pour les
aider
je pense que c'est le rêve
son rêve
lee kai kai est lui l'a réalisé en
reprenant voici une vingtaine d'années
l'exploitation familiale
il remet en valeur à sa manière ce
terrain vallonné des eaux de petites
îles au départ il y avait du maraîchage
après m'acquitter maraîchage mamie la
can est aujourd'hui bien me revient
culture et ancien pote manioc non ici
pas de machine dans tous les trophées à
la main et tout à fait à la main le
nettoyage tout et puis l'arrachage à la
main simi fait une rotation au cimetière
manuel mais patatras tout ça ne tient
pas terminée manioc moi ici pas d'andré
pas de fumier ces deux cultures pour moi
ben
normal qu amélie tient pas de pâte à pau
en d'engrais ou de pesticides résultats
des plans c'est et vigoureux avec des
conditions de culture quasi bio michael
cultive ici principalement une seule
variété le manioc blanc selon une
technique que lui a appris son père
l'exemple soit pas planté au fond
regarde le banc de manioc est juste à la
surface de la terre
juste ça c'est ma plante au fond
pourquoi me plante pas au fond c'est
quand on plante au fond ils donnent plus
au fond et quand il aller pour arracher
ou après cette force morale chez les
plantes jusqu'à la surface à terre oumar
koné que quand on prend comme ça avec
une maniaque lien direct et plus souple
en te font belle manière et donne au
fond de 109 ont ils m'ont pas donc ça
c'est toute une technique ou la prix
notamment écoute pas pareil ça m'a plu
va pas tout le travail que m'a appris
c'est papa montre moins tout le travail
commun a pris mal pris et lui me veux tu
comprends pas ce chou plants de manioc
au fond mais plus haut point de fonds
puis sur le fond est déjà lui l'est
moins 6 parce que là un coup jeté dessus
il tient très froid et lui les moins -
cana de la terre c'est une manière la
plus rapide
indemne des maladies graves qui ravage
les plantations de nombreux pays
africains
notre manioc pays pourrait permettre
demain de créer et de développer de
nouvelles variétés plus résistantes
quasiment totale fleurissent sur
yssingeaux et et on peut donc on peut
faire des croisements et qu'il crée des
créer de nouvelles variétés
donc c'est l'objectif c'est bien de
d'aller chercher des résistances
variétale dans des variétés à ce qu'on
n'a pas des variétés pays
et puis de le produire ces résistances
dans des variétés très productive de
manière pour avoir des résistances aux
maladies au virus ont perçu la réunion
est indemne effectivement ne sait de ces
virus et ce qui nous permet d'avoir une
situation bien particulière est donc
l'objectif aussi de ces de cette réunion
c'est de trouver des solutions pour que
cvc ces virus ne vienne n'arrive pas à
la réunion elle quand on arrive à
conserver d une production de manière
qui soit la plus saine possible mais
pour l'heure michael payet continue de
cultiver avec soin ses précieuses
racines en attendant sa prochaine
récolte de manioc dans deux mois en fin
de compte c'est manioc classera à une
grosse heure comme ça donc les gros
c'est idéal pour vendre ça ça ça la
grosse un impeccable
voilà oui car la quantité de manioc en
achètent et de manioc l énorme
franchement oui il faut pas avoir peur
de lever le matin grand matin rien
travailler c'est tout apprécié outils
que una douleur ou lève pas où on sera
trois il faut il faut lever et aller
travailler
et là on va gagner de manger ses parents
le courage c'est tout
oh